Speaker 1: We now are learning more and more
about what was actually a coordinated plan
to send fraudulent electors in multiple states
to Washington, D.C. to try to steal the election
from Joe Biden.
As a reminder, Joe Biden won the election
in November of 2020.
There was a concerted effort made across a
number of different areas to try to steal
the election by Donald Trump.
We now know that Rudy Giuliani was at the
helm of a fake elector plot in seven states.
Rudy may now have legal problems as a result.
CNN reporting.
WASHINGTON I'm sorry.
Trump campaign officials led by Giuliani oversaw
efforts in December of 2020 to put forward
illegitimate electors from seven states that
Trump lost, according to three sources with
direct knowledge of the scheme.
The sources said members of Trump's former
campaign team were far more involved than
previously known.
A core tenet of the broader plot to overturn
Joe Biden's victory on January 6th.
Giuliani and allies coordinated the nuts and
bolts of the process on a state by state level,
the sources told CNN.
One source said there were multiple planning
calls between Trump campaign officials and
Republican state operatives and that Giuliani
participated in at least one call.
The source also said that the Trump campaign
lined up supporters to fill elector slots,
secured meeting rooms in state houses for
the fake electors to meet on December 14th
and circulated drafts of fake certificates
that were ultimately sent to the National
Archives.
Trump and some of his top advisers publicly
encouraged the alternate electors scheme in
Pennsylvania, Georgia, Michigan, Arizona,
Wisconsin, Nevada and New York.
But behind the scenes, Giuliani and Trump
campaign officials actively choreograph the
process, the source said.
They were going to try to dump in
Speaker 6: big, massive dumps fake
Speaker 1: electors to vote for Trump instead
of Biden.
We already knew this.
Remember that we actually talked about this
not long ago.
One of the Republican lawmakers who signed
the fake Arizona document was State Representative
Jake Hoffman.
He was confronted about this and said, Who
organized this?
Who told you to show up that day and sign
this fraudulent document?
He ran away from reporters.
And remember, we looked at this clip
Speaker 4: when Bram wants to ask a real question.
Happy to have a conversation with him.
Thank you, sir.
Oh.
Unidentified: Richard Wallace made a couple
of things.
That being one of their cell phones was electric.
Speaker 4: I'm going to be I'm asking you
that question.
I wonder, what authority did you find yourself
as a collector?
So in unprecedented times, unprecedented action
is occurred.
There is no case law.
There's no precedent that exists as to whether
or not a an election that is currently being
litigated in the courts has to do standing,
which is why we felt it appropriate to provide
Congress and the vice president with dueling
opinions.
Did you have direction from anybody in doing
this?
Was it you 11 yourself to doing this or that
someone give you advice on the manner in which
you can do it?
I'm done.
So I'm simply I was one of the electors.
Right, right.
I'm not in charge of the electors.
So you would.
How did you hear what you went through here?
You would need to ask the attorney general,
How did you hear about the plan?
What you just told to be something you would
need to ask the party chair that but you're
the you're the person who received the call.
You showed up, right?
How did you know to show up that day?
So as I said, you can go ahead and ask the
party chair the logistics of it, ask her how
you got a phone call to someone.
You're welcome to talk to them about.
Do you not know how you arrived at a place?
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
You really know how you got a call.
Have a great one.
The other question I was hoping to answer.
Speaker 1: So this needs to be taken completely
seriously.
If at the individual level you fill out a
fake ballot, sometimes you go to jail.
We've seen that happen at the individual level.
They tried to steal the whole election and
all of a sudden it's like, Well, what are
we going to do anything about that?
Might we file charges?
It's a federal crime to interfere with the
mail.
But if you're the postmaster general, you
can sabotage the whole system, make it more
difficult to vote by mail, and there's no
repercussions.
It's common that at the street level, things
are punished.
And then at the structural level, they are
not.
Now all of this goes back to one of the many
prongs that they had in place to try to steal
the election.
One prong was that if there are states that
they just won't accept were won by Joe Biden
on January 6th or December 14th, depending
on how the plan went.
Instead of sending only the Democratic electors
to D.C., what Republicans wanted to do was
send an alternate slate of electors, and they
wanted to force Mike Pence when it came time
for Arizona's votes to be counted, for example,
for Mike Pence to say because the results
of Arizona seem fake.
I mean, I don't even know how you say it and
not sound like a complete authoritarian clown.
Instead of accepting the Democratic votes
from Arizona, we have these other what's the
number seven?
14.
I don't remember these other electors from
Arizona.
Well, how do you vote?
We vote for Trump.
That was the plan.
Now that plan failed.
But understand that if they had had different
people in place at the state level, if Trump
had had the generals with him, as was warned
now a couple of weeks ago by retired military
generals, the outcome could have been different.
It's really great that it failed, given how
badly it could have gone.
But this was a plan for a complete coup, including
possibly declaring a state of emergency was
being floated, trying to get the military
to enforce a different winner.
Fake electors flipping states by pressuring
secretaries of state.
They are going to try it again.
We just saw.
They don't even know.
Joni Ernst asked, What are three things you
would do?
She has nothing.
So they're not trying to win on policy.
They are going to try this again.
And we have to be ready for it.
And we'll have more on this on our Instagram.
Find us on Instagram at David
Pakman show.